how powerful is Hamas the Palestinian
group that attacked Israel on October
7th massacring hundreds of civilians and
kidnapping many others Hamas is an
islamist organization and political
party that runs the Gaza Strip home to 2
million Palestinians it was founded in
1987 during the First Palestinian
Uprising against Israel's occupation of
Gaza and the West
Bank its name is short for Islamic
resistance movement in
Arabic its founding Charter called for
the destruction of the state of Israel
and the killing of
Jews since its formation Hamas has
carried out suicide bombings rocket
attacks and
kidnappings which led some countries to
designate the group as a terrorist
organization in 2006 it won a majority
of seats in the Palestinian
elections a year later after a brief
Civil War Hamas took full control of
Gaza and no more elections were
held Israel and Egypt placed a blockade
on the
Strip strangling its economy and
confining its
people despite the blockade Hamas has
built up its military capacity from
smuggled support from allies including
Iran since 2008 it has launched five
Wars against
Israel the most recent attack was far
more sophisticated than any that came
before suggesting that its capabilities
have grown larger than many
assumed Hamas managed to breach the
defenses of one of the world's most
militarily advanced
nations with devastating
consequences